SARAH KARAM: So we are
going to get some chairs up
on stage, along with
our wonderful panelists.
While we're doing that,
while we are getting set up,
we are going to talk about
building with empathy.
I would imagine not
many of you guys
talk about this on a daily
basis or in your 2018 planning
or anything like that.
So I thought, it's been
a couple of minutes.
Just teeing up what that means.
And some perspectives on what
we're going to talk about.
Thank you.
Thanks.
So empathy, the ability
to understand and share
the feelings of another.
The American Association
of Psychology
proposes it is the defining
trait that makes us human.
And the absence of
which enables things
like oppression, persecution,
violence, warfare,
all the rotten things in life.
So I think on a personal
level, on a one-to-one basis,
we all agree that it is an
incredibly important quality
and something that I hope we
all try to exude in daily lives.
But what does it mean
on a business level?
What does it mean if
you're building products,
making decisions every day?
Can you do that with empathy?
And does it matter?
Should you do that?
What are the costs
of not doing that?
Or doing that?
And there are really
two key perspectives
to think about this.
One is, as the business
decision-maker, or the product
decision-maker, can
you be empathy-driven?
You know, we talk about
data-driven all the time.
And we use it as
a positive trait.
You know, he's data-driven
and he's amazing.
But we rarely talk about being
empathy-driven and thinking
about that in your
decision-making.
And an example that came to
mind when thinking about this
was Wonder Bread.
And I don't know how many--
I didn't grow up in the US.
So for me, Wonder Bread
was kind of a revelation
when I moved here.
I've never tasted it.
But they pioneered sliced
bread in the 1920s.
You know, they were kind of seen
as a huge innovator in the food
industry.
The term, "the best
thing since sliced bread"
from Wonder Bread.
They saw huge success
in the 1950s and '60s.
About 25% to 30% of
American caloric intake
was Wonder Bread.
Nothing has been as
prolific since then.
Not Coca-Cola, not high
fructose corn syrup.
In 2012, they filed
for bankruptcy.
And you know, obviously
many reasons for that.
But one of the main
reasons that is suggested
is the rise of health
food, organic food,
as [INAUDIBLE] was mentioning.
Greater awareness.
And if you were
a product manager
at Wonder Bread in the
1950s, and you proposed
to do an A/B test to
sell whole wheat bread,
I wonder how many of us
would have been successful
with the A/B test.
Or whether the leadership of
the company would have been,
ah, it is a great idea.
Go ahead with that.
And I think what is interesting
is that often there can
be a trade-off potentially
between performance
and building a better
experience, a more enriching
experience for your users.
And how do you
make that trade-off
and how do you
even know if you're
going in the right direction?
And the other perspective, which
is incredibly relevant to you
all, as technology product
managers, decision-makers,
is the need to build
products with empathy.
Now with the rise
of voice search,
we're seeing over a billion
voice queries on Google
now per week, with
assistance and AI
and new models of engaging
with users and natural language
processing.
Users expect your product
to behave like a person.
And more than that, to
behave like a friend.
And your friend isn't
always nice to you.
Your friend is not
robotic, kind of answering
in binary ones and zeros.
Your friend understands you.
And the same-- you
don't expect the same.
So Esha might have a
friend who she expects
to behave in a certain way.
I have a different expectation,
like we saw in the IDEO video.
So it is a very
challenging problem.
So with that, I would
love to introduce my three
wonderful panelists.
As you guys do quick
intros, I'm going
to scan through images
of your products.
So you guys can talk
a bit about that.
Go ahead.
ESHA GUPTA: Great.
Well, thanks for
having us here today.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Esha Gupta.
I am a co-founder and the
director of content at Hooked,
which is a chat fiction app.
We currently have
30 million readers,
and our goal with Hooked is to
redefine the way that people
read and write and
consume fiction stories
on their phones.
SAM MANDEL: Hi, I'm Sam Mandel.
I'm the CEO of Poncho.
I'm also a partner
at Beta Works,
which is the start-up
studio in New York where
Poncho was created.
Our goal with Poncho is
to create a new weather
service aimed at millennials
and younger people.
But as we thought
about what that meant,
we decided we wanted
to create kind
of an experience of
getting the weather
from a friend, or a
friendly acquaintance,
or something in that category.
And we are really
trying to do two things.
One is figure out
what it means to have
native content for
the messaging layer,
because we felt like that is
where Poncho should really
live.
And the other is
eventually how to build
a UI that would work
for AI back ends
and how we could bring
that sort of friendliness
on the front end to more
data-driven, and assembling
sort of a data
package, like weather.
Now, one of the ways we do that,
we actually have two comedy
writers on our team.
And they are comedians by night
and write for Poncho by day.
And they actually
write the forecast.
But everything else
we do with Poncho
is sort of done algorithmically,
both on our apps
for iOS and Android.
And also, we have one
of the best chatbots
out there on Facebook
Messenger and a couple
of other platforms.
In fact, we just got our
Webby award yesterday.
It finally came
in the mail and--
SARAH KARAM: Congratulations.
SAM MANDEL: --it said
"World's Best Chatbot" on it,
so we're proud.
DANIELLE KRETTEK:
That's awesome.
I hope you are sharing
it with Poncho.
SAM MANDEL: Absolutely.
DANIELLE KRETTEK: I'm Danielle.
I run Google's Empathy Lab.
And the way that that kind of
works at a place like Google,
is I work with our research
and machine intelligence
gang, sort of on all of the
guts in the intelligence,
the souls of these things.
Also with the Assistant gang.
And then am deeply embedded
in the design organization
as well.
Because, you know, everybody
needs some empathy.
So basically, I work
across all of those teams,
and connecting those
teams, kind of as the glue.
And a way that I often
talk about my work
is, Google is incredible at IQ.
And what we are really
starting to build and develop
at this point is our EQ.
Because you can imagine, if
our EQ was equal to our IQ,
how compelling the space is.
And I think, for this
new design paradigm,
which is about sort of
interaction relationship,
it's like-- it is an imperative
now, rather than something
that's just like oh, its
this, like, squishy layer.
Or sort of like
design once was--
this great thing that some
people got and other people
didn't.
It's like, we're at
that stage with this.
It's like, are we
going to acknowledge
what's really happening here?
So--
SARAH KARAM: Awesome.
Well, thank you all so
much for being here.
Esha, I would love
to start with you.
You know, Hooked, given
its focus on chat stories--
you know, stories are inherently
kind of empathetic and all
about relating to one another.
Was building your products
with that in mind,
and building kind
of a personality
into your product,
an obvious endeavor?
Or was it something that
kind of had to come about,
and you had to kind of
make big product decisions
to decide how to do
that within the UI?
ESHA GUPTA: Yeah,
that's a great question.
So I think the
short answer to that
is, there wasn't a lot
of conscious discussion
or decision around building
a personality into the app.
I think we think about it more
in terms of, what is, I guess,
the personality of the
main character of a story.
And how does that speak
to the audience we're
trying to target that story to?
But what I will say, and I just
want to circle back and kind
of piggyback off of the
Wonder Bread analogy,
because I just
think it's so good.
And it made me, as you were
saying it, think about,
maybe we are kind of
experiencing like our Wonder
Bread moment with mobile.
And what I mean
by that is, we've
sort of had this
first slew of apps
that have come out that
are really addicting
and we're using them
constantly and they are really
entertaining, but
perhaps they leave
us feeling a little bit
dissatisfied and kind
of unhappy at times.
You know, we probably--
we're at peak social.
We're all maybe spending a
lot more time on social media
than we like.
And that experience,
I think, sometimes
leaves us feeling just--
like there's a
lack of something.
And so, in many ways,
that is the reason
why we started Hooked.
We felt like we wanted to be
kind of a whole-wheat option.
And you know, there
isn't sort of a lot of--
there isn't a lot
of options out there
that feel like a nourishing
alternative to what
is out there.
And so yeah, so I think
with that in mind,
we thought, OK, well,
there are many studies that
show that there is a high
correlation between the amount
of fiction a person consumes and
their ability to score highly
or well on tests that measure
empathy and social skills,
and even happiness.
And so you take that
idea in and of itself,
plus just the team's
personal experience
of reading and feeling like
you're sort of building empathy
in this meditative state.
So how do you take those
facts and experiences
and translate them into
an experience for mobile,
basically?
And so that's kind of like
where our whole journey started.
And I think, from
our perspective, too,
you can't really expect
us to put down our phones.
I don't think that
we are ever going
to ever reach a point
where we are going
to live in a digital detox.
And so, that said, it
is sort of like, OK,
how do you start creating
those more nourishing,
like, whole-wheat options
that still taste really good
and are really,
really addicting,
but also leave
you feeling better
than maybe the Wonder
Breads of the world?
SARAH KARAM: I like that
you carried that through.
Maybe we'll just have
goggles, and then,
who needs to hold anything?
It will all be
right in your face.
Sam, you are the token
male on the panel.
So thank you for being that.
SAM MANDEL: It is great for
a change, I have to say.
SARAH KARAM: So
you're approaching
this kind of with two hats.
You know, Poncho is a start-up.
And you also advise other
companies as well as start-ups.
Do you find that given-- we
are all resource-constrained,
but especially at a start-up,
you've got to make trade-offs.
Do you find it--
have you ever had to make those
tough decisions between like,
well, we need to really grow
our core metric, whatever
that is right now.
And it could be at the expense
of this really enriching,
engaging experience that we
spend all our time building.
Or you always kind
of know at your heart
that the Poncho character,
and investing in that,
and the comedic side
of it, is always
going to trump more
money, more engagement?
SAM MANDEL: You know, we are
just reaching that point now
in our history.
I think up till
now it's been easy,
because really engagement
was the core metric we
used internally, and
engagement and retention.
And we felt like
that was the best.
Our goal was to become part
of people's daily routine.
You know, we see the average
user like twice a day.
We have, I think, by far the
highest chatbot retention of I
think any bot.
And our app retention
is very, very high, too.
And so we sort of--
those goals and what we
were measuring sort of
reinforced this
idea that we wanted
to be friends with the user,
not abuse that relationship.
When we send notifications,
we specifically design them
so you don't have to open them.
One of the other weather
apps sends one saying, like,
check out the weather today.
And we actually give
you the weather,
so that our use case
paradigm is sort of,
you're in bed in
the morning, you're
looking at your texts and
messages from your friends,
and you have one from Poncho
that tells you the weather.
So that was-- we didn't
have to really push it.
Now we're just
starting a project
where we are going to try and
sell-- have Poncho sell things
to you.
And so we really--
and we know that not all
users are going to like that.
And we have to figure
out-- we think of Poncho
as a virtual influencer.
We want to build him up
as a character who you can
relate to and buy things from.
And so the way we've
approached that, we've
done some experiments,
and there was definitely
some user pushback.
We're now going to-- we're now
doing a bigger series of tests,
basically towards
launching a product that
is going to have some Poncho
branding on it that we're
doing in partnership.
And the first thing we
did was create a backstory
for why it's happening.
We have a character bible for
Poncho that we've written,
and most of that is not
really visible to users.
Like, I know Poncho's
major in college,
which was Canadian film.
But we've never revealed
that to the user.
SARAH KARAM: Now we all know.
SAM MANDEL: But it
just sort of helps us--
it just helps us sort of
get in the mood for like,
is this something he would do?
Is this something
he would not do?
And that has to do with
creating someone who--
he is sort of a friend, but
we think of him as almost
between a friend and
acquaintance, sort of.
Like he's not your
best friend, but he's
somebody you're friendly with.
And so we thought, OK, well,
why would he be selling this?
And now we're going to go
forward and basically do
a lot of A/B testing
in terms of--
with subsets of our users,
to see what there is the most
pushback to.
But we always want to
be transparent about it.
And a big part of that
story is going to be,
like, Poncho's rent went up.
And you know, he
lives in Brooklyn.
And he's got to make his rent.
And his job at Poncho,
Inc. where he works
is not cutting it.
So he's got this
kind of side gig.
And then we're going to
test how much of that
we expose to the users.
Our goal is to sell the product.
It's not necessarily to be
consistent with the story.
Although the writers and the
whole team, the engineers too,
we all get into the story.
And we always have to
fight that temptation
to surface too much of that.
And our goal is to
surface just enough of it
so that we don't
get this pushback.
But we do think of
ourselves as being
sort of in a relationship
with the user.
And we think that that drives
a lot of our retention.
Because people feel like
if they delete the Poncho
app or something, they just
feel a little guilty about it,
is what people have told us.
SARAH KARAM: "I deleted Poncho."
SAM MANDEL: And so
we want to approach
even things that the user--
might not be their first choice
to see advertising or commerce
in Poncho.
But we want to be
transparent in a way that's
true to the character
about why we're doing that.
So we'll just see how that goes.
But we're trying to do
that in the same spirit
as we've designed the
rest of the service.
SARAH KARAM: So you
talked about testing.
And Danielle, I imagine this
must be like a Herculean feat
at Google, to try to get people
out of the mindset of purely
data-driven--
you know, there's 60
whatever here, and 59 here.
We're going with the 60.
How have you approached
moving people
into more of an EQ
measurement mindset?
And are you doing
that quantifiably?
Have you found ways to do that?
Or does it need to be more
qualitative and about CSAT
and softer metrics?
DANIELLE KRETTEK: It's
got to be all of it.
I mean, the thing that kind
of is like the blessing
and the curse of this space
is that it's invisible.
We're trying to literally
make things visible
that are invisible.
We're also trying to
make things comfortable
that are uncomfortable.
Like in terms of
talking about feelings,
it's like, I literally will just
walk into a room and be like,
we're going to talk
about feelings today.
And people are like,
face-melting terror, right?
So I think it's kind of
just tackling that head on
and saying, humans are messy.
There's the rational
and the irrational.
There's the stuff
that makes sense.
you can research,
the stuff that is
unresearchable.
The whole point of
talking to people
and understanding
the full story.
There was a great line
from a psychologist
that I work with, who
was basically, like,
the only way that you can know a
person, and to truly know them,
is when you know their story.
So when we look at the
full story, some of that
is going to be the pattern
recognition in the metrics.
And some of it is going to be
all of the narrative superglue
and messiness that kind of
makes them and their life.
And so what I make a big point
of doing in my conversations
with our gang at Google is to
quote the Martian and science
the shit out of it.
What I tend to do is speak a
lot about the way people feel
and experience things.
And I get into a lot of that.
I make a lot of short
documentary films
that sort of let people
tell their own stories.
And really, when you
think about films,
you're making feelings,
like, in the other person.
When you're telling a story,
you're making feelings.
And so what I try to do is have
those stories tell themselves.
And then there is so much
around emotional intelligence
and social intelligence,
and you know, the psychology
of these spaces, that what I
find myself doing is, instead
of trying to invent
new metrics, is
to look at the metrics that
are out there around machine
intelligence and the idea of
learning someone and growing
with someone and getting to know
them better in a hit or a miss,
and then fill that in with
things like the Gottmans'
method.
So, show of hands
for folks in the room
that know the Gottmans?
It means you all probably
have wonderful marriages.
So the Gottmans got
famous in the '90s
for-- basically they were the
people where you could sit down
with them for 20 minutes, and
they would tell you, like,
how long your marriage
was going to last.
They had their "Love Lab."
SARAH KARAM: Like
a fortune teller?
How would they know?
DANIELLE KRETTEK:
They basically, they
were all the kind
of micro-gestures.
And like all of that stuff.
And then, also just like
galvanic-- you know,
all the labby stuff.
But they could literally
sit with you for 20 minutes
and be like, you guys
aren't going to make it.
You'll make it seven years.
You'll make it 14 years.
And I mean, can you
imagine the stress?
Like the worst dinner
party guests ever.
But what's rad about
what they did is,
they also became known for--
like kind of in the
'90s, when divorce
was hockey sticking-- this
idea of the magic ratio, which
is five to one.
And so the way that that
works is, for every five
positive interactions
that you have,
it's OK if there is one bad one.
And what was interesting
about this is,
it was like basically
agnostic to coupling style.
People were like, oh, my God,
if we like, you know, fight
all the time, but we
make up all the time,
is that better than if we
are like conflict diverse?
Or is it worse?
Or like, who is
going to make it?
It was like the fear.
Like people care about
their relationships.
And they were like,
it doesn't matter.
What matters is the ratio.
It's like, people have
used like the piggy bank.
You know, putting
points in the bank
and all that stuff--
other metaphors for it.
But I think what's
interesting about that
is, I've run a lot of
research saying, well,
if we're in a
paradigm where this
is the interface, and
its relationship-driven,
then the rules for
relationships and what
works should borrow over here.
And what I found is that
five-to-one metric bears out.
So when you're
designing the research,
how are you asking the
right narrative questions
to get at the truth.
I mean, like I immediately
am like, oh, my God,
I wonder if people
with Poncho are
going to be, like, how is
the side hustle going, man?
Like in the morning.
Like if I were to
get a text from him,
I would be like, how's it going?
And these types of things.
How do you design for that messy
space and at the same time,
be looking at the really
core architectures of what
feels right in a relationship?
The five-to-one is just,
like, when it feels right.
I feel like I'm
constantly trying
to find ways to
put pins on things
that are the most uncomfortable,
weird parts of being human.
SAM MANDEL: You
know, can I just say,
when we designed
the Poncho bot, I'd
never heard of that
five-to-one ratio.
I'm sure none of
the team knows it.
But we just decided that
we had to, basically,
if you asked the Poncho bot
a question about the weather,
we had to understand
it 80% of the time.
And if we couldn't do that,
then we weren't succeeding.
And so, it's kind of funny
that that-- we just--
but we, as a collective,
we sat around,
we were like, that's the
metric that we have to go for.
DANIELLE KRETTEK: That's
a good point, too,
because I think you guys
intuitively got there.
And that's kind of the
head bleep of the space.
Is if you really check
in, if you drop in, you--
we all know the answers
of what feels good,
what doesn't feel good, what
we believe, what we don't.
What story, like, actually--
I mean, literally using your
app, I was like, oh, my God,
it's not loading fast enough.
Like, why doesn't this
story text me faster?
And that sense of
when you're in it,
versus when you're out of it.
And I think it's, how do we
find metrics that actually match
that, versus being
driven by what's
the actual best
metric for this thing.
We can kind of get
lost in our heads.
Like a big thing I talk
about is how we often
think that we're designing
for people's modes,
like airplane mode, this, that,
what game mode, stress mode.
I think what's funny
is, people when they--
like a research project I
ran that you know about was,
I was, like, OK,
it's really weird
to ask people what their
ideal flow of information
is for notifications and
this, that, and the other.
And people were kind of
asking me about the tray.
And I was like, OK,
forget the tray.
Like, I went to people
and I was like, you
know what airplane mode is.
Give me like 10 more.
And all of their
modes were moods.
They weren't modes at all.
So just that, like, little- the
extra "o" makes a difference.
I think intuitively being
like, oh, I think that's right.
How do I make a metric for that?
SARAH KARAM: You talked
about kind of maybe mimicking
a great relationship
where you've
got kind of this good ratio
of positive and negative.
But in that paradigm, you as
a person in that relationship,
you are yourself.
You are not a machine.
You can't switch who
you are, and have
an equally effective
relationship with somebody
else.
You can do that in
your product, right?
So you can be a different
person to one user
and another to another user.
Is that-- I guess, how do
you think about that when
you're building-- and you know,
for others in the audience who
are either building your own
natural language interface,
or you are just kind of thinking
about your brand personality--
do you stay as one brand?
Or do you mimic
whatever the user wants?
And what are the
trade-offs there?
And how do you guys
think about that?
ESHA GUPTA: Yeah,
well, I'll jump in here
and say that, one
interesting thing that
happened in the past year
with Hooked that we noticed
is that, when we first started
collecting stories for the app,
our main goal was to get stories
that were super addicting.
Because we're like, OK, goal
is to get people to read.
How do you do that?
You need like
Buzzfeed of fiction.
You need it to be
super addicting.
People want to tap,
get to the end.
And so when we
first started out,
we incentivized authors
for that particular metric.
The metric of success
we were measuring
was completion rate of stories.
And so we collected
a bunch of stories
that had really high
engagement, and we
thought all was going well.
And then we ran
sentiment analysis
after we had a good
collection of stories,
I think about, like,
200, 250, on the comments
and the likes-to-loves
ratios and like,
the positive to negative
words in the comments.
We just ran a huge
analysis of, can we
gauge what people actually
feel about this story?
And what we learned
is that people
hated cliffhanger endings.
They were so angry that they
would get to the end of a story
and it wouldn't
have this resolute,
kind of satisfying ending.
And they felt almost betrayed.
And so what we saw is
that, well, first of all,
it's really hard to write
a good ending to any story.
And that's just like a challenge
of writing a good fiction
story.
But it's particularly
challenging
in a compressed format with the
goal of being super engaging
in such a short amount of time.
And so we kind of went
back to the drawing board.
And we're like,
OK, this is clearly
important from an emotional
perspective for our readers.
And so we changed our
incentive structure
and asked authors to
revisit their stories,
and then moving
forward, like really
invest in thinking about
how to write endings
with more closure.
And then we re-ran the
sentiment analysis,
and user satisfaction
just shot way up.
And so I use incentives
as an example
because I think it wasn't,
though in retrospect it's
obvious, it wasn't something
we were really thinking
about in the beginning.
And this was something we
heard from our readers,
like across the board,
that they wanted.
And so we did sort of maneuver
ourselves to cater to that.
Because what it taught us
is that measuring based
on just one metric,
engagement, isn't enough.
We have to always ask ourselves
with every story, what
is the emotional experience
that this person is potentially
having with this
piece as a whole?
Is it good or is it bad?
And if it's bad, we need to
figure out how to make it good.
SARAH KARAM: Yeah, I imagine.
I don't know if any media
producers are in the room.
And Netflix, I
have a bone to pick
with every original
content piece.
Because everything
is a cliffhanger.
And it forces you
to keep staying
addicted to a specific show.
But I mean, I think it
goes back to whether--
users are not necessarily
always having a positive feeling
after their interaction
with your product.
And is that-- do you always
want to make the user happy?
I know that is a
strange question.
But in real life,
the people who you
want to be around all
the time don't always
kind of placate to your every
need, to keep you smiling.
I think in the IDEO study,
there was an example of somebody
who said they wanted somebody to
challenge them, or kind of not
let them get away with
doing whatever they want.
Is that something
that you can build in?
And should build into products?
SAM MANDEL: I don't
know if this is--
maybe this isn't the exact
same question you're asking.
But we look at a lot of
the digital assistants.
Because Poncho is kind of a
digital assistant in some ways.
And one of the
things we consciously
decided we didn't
want to do with Poncho
is make him too accommodating.
You know, because
I think that one
of the issues with
digital assistants
is that they are
pretty subservient.
And because they all have
female personalities,
it's sort of like even worse.
And it just--
there's just some--
I think they can
get a little creepy.
And they're also not human.
Because human--
SARAH KARAM: Except the
Google Assistant, right?
SAM MANDEL: The
Google Assistant is--
SARAH KARAM: I'm just kidding.
SAM MANDEL: I like the Google
Assistant because it is so dry.
Like it sort of--
it feels more robotic
in a good way.
But like it's not trying
to do anything else.
But I think that the--
DANIELLE KRETTEK:
Are you saying this
because I'm sitting
right next to you?
[LAUGHTER]
SAM MANDEL: But I think
the Google Assistant
has a certain dryness.
I really do mean that.
But in a positive way.
Like it's not pretending
to be a person exactly.
But I think that with
Poncho, we decided
like, he's going to be
somebody who you're not--
he is not your best friend.
He has his own things to do.
So even little
messages, sometimes,
like when you talk to the
chatbot, and he's like,
hey, I was charging my phone.
Sorry.
You know, I didn't
see you there.
Or something like that.
SARAH KARAM: But can I ask why?
Like was that an-- sorry to
interrupt you, but was that
an obvious choice?
To think of him
as you didn't want
him to be your best friend?
SAM MANDEL: We didn't
want him to be servile.
We wanted him to be someone who
you wanted to be friends with.
Like he was a little
cooler than you.
And you were sort
of trying to like--
you know, we wanted to
have that relationship,
because we thought that
was just more intriguing,
and people would be--
we always want people to
kind of try to know more.
Now, that being said,
we want their reaction
when they've used Poncho.
Like our user
promise is that sort
of moment of zen in the morning.
And you know, we
think about what
that-- our use case is
basically morning use
of the average user.
We have like two
sessions a day per user.
But we think about that morning
use case as fundamental.
And we want-- especially
now, like, things have just
gotten worse, like you
dread opening your phone.
You know, who knows
what is in the news?
We just want that
moment to leave you
with a little bit of a smile.
And that's kind of
our brand promise.
So if we don't succeed
there, then we're
not delivering what
we've promised to do.
DANIELLE KRETTEK:
I think another way
to answer your
question, too, is about,
like, the identity
being elastic.
Having a sense of
elasticity to it,
so that it can change over
time in a narrative arc,
so that it can change in
skills that are added.
Or things like
Poncho's side hustle.
I think the thing that we know
to be most true about humans
is that we change.
And we're never one thing.
And just when we think
we've figured ourselves out,
we're kind of not that.
Like learning and growing
and figuring it out
and not feeling like you
have anything figured out.
And like the human
experience being
like this, whether you
screenshot it as a day,
or whether you look
at it as a movie arc.
I mean, "Boyhood" and
"ET" are two of the--
like I have two
four-minute edits for both
of those that I
use constantly when
I talk about machine learning.
And the reason why
is that we understand
growth and change and
variability and personality,
and when things are great,
and when things suck,
and the fact that all
of that's welcome.
We understand that
in the context
of each other and stories.
And if you can apply a backstory
and background and narrative.
And like, tech isn't
perfect, and assistance
won't be perfect.
And the weather
is unpredictable.
And maybe Poncho is mysterious,
or the assistance this or that.
I think just that sense of--
the best speakers,
the best films,
the things that really move
you and you feel connected to,
that bond is because
they make you feel
a little bit of everything.
SARAH KARAM: Yep.
DANIELLE KRETTEK: And I think
that little bit of everything
is something that you
design in with a light hand.
But an assistant
that is a cheerleader
and is always kind of a positive
thing would drive you crazy.
It would be like
Reese Witherspoon
from "Election"
following him around.
No, right?
So I think we often want to
go to the positive high-note
place.
But that's not where we live.
So how do we get really
authentic and vulnerable
about that?
And like designing for
those spaces with these--
I mean, the thing about
devices and our experiences
with these presences
now is it's 24/7.
The on-off switch is a joke.
They're everywhere.
So we need a lot
more granularity
and gradient in that aspect of
the experience emotionally now.
SARAH KARAM: We have
a couple of minutes.
I would love-- I don't know
how many of you in the audience
do a lot of thinking
in this space,
or if you already have kind
of ways to measure longer term
empathy, emotion, all that.
If not, you know, what would
you guys give as advice?
You know, as you guys have
started thinking about this,
if you were doing it
again from scratch,
or just starting this, what
are some things that you
would recommend to
anyone in that position?
ESHA GUPTA: I guess--
this is maybe going
to sound generic.
We as a team,
internally, often are
debating which direction to go.
It's usually a 50/50 split.
And we will have
emotional reactions
to what we think we should do.
But then we always just
kind of settle back
into just testing it, and
seeing what the results are.
But when they are close,
taking it with a grain of salt.
And so like for the
ending of stories,
ultimately, financially,
it wasn't a great decision
because we had to
pay our authors more
for the same amount of stories.
But we decided
that, kind of based
on just like the
negativity surrounding
the emotional experience
for our readers,
that it might be
something worth doing.
And even though, maybe,
there isn't an actual data
point around how it's
increased our revenue
from that perspective, the
point is, users seem happier.
And so therefore,
for us, it's a win.
And so, I think--
I don't know.
There's not like-- emotions
are, like Danielle is saying,
you can't measure them with
quite as much granularity.
And so--
SARAH KARAM: You
trust your intuition?
ESHA GUPTA: You just have
to trust your intuition.
It's like, does this
thing make me feel shitty?
Or does it make me feel good?
You know, and if the
answer is pretty clear,
I feel like that should be
the thing that helps you point
your arrow in either direction.
SARAH KARAM: Sam, Danielle, do
you guys have words of wisdom
for new entrants to the space?
DANIELLE KRETTEK: I think,
well, I'd say like two things.
Like we all know that moment
in the movie where you're like,
don't go in there.
There's this thing
where, I think,
as we're designing stuff, it's
like, when you're following
your feelings, when you're in
an experience, your intuition,
whether you're someone that
acknowledges that or not,
is in play.
And I think when we
tend to design stuff,
we look at it within
the container.
So it's like blow
away the container.
And then, I think
the other piece
of that is the
invitation for you,
in whatever function or
discipline you are in, is to--
like we really do need to
tap all of our humanity
as we are working
on these things.
Like with this
interaction space,
you're not just the designer,
the researcher, the PM,
the whatever.
You've got to bring
the human piece.
Because it's the
mess that is going
to make this stuff
believable, that's
going to make it compelling.
And it's going to
make it welcome.
Because I think
the endgame of all
of this that's potentially
there is, like,
this world can either
feel really harmonious
with all of these kind of
helpful agents and friends
and things.
It's like your social
circle expands.
Or it's like total
schizophrenia.
So that's like where,
in 1987, like Apple
had their HCI principles.
And we are, like, here's
how this needs to work.
And I think we are all
working on that recipe
together right now.
SAM MANDEL: I would just say
I have always wanted to--
I was a philosophy
major in college.
So I'm going to quote Immanuel
Kant, the great German
philosopher.
Probably never been done
in a Google event before.
But he had this
thing where he said,
like, you treat
people ethically,
you should treat them
as ends in themselves,
not as a means to an end.
And I do think about that
in terms of like app design
and product design.
We shouldn't think
of our users as means
to our end, where we're trying
to drive certain metrics.
You know, we try to think,
OK, what do they want to do?
And are we helping them do that?
And that's kind of our--
that's our fundamental design
principle.
SARAH KARAM: Yeah, wise words.
Thank you all so
much for joining us.
In a segue we're actually
going to be talking to Brad--
or Brad is going be talking
about the Assistant.
So very relevant to
this conversation.
Yeah, thank you again.
Thanks everyone for being here.